julie juil qu'at-il casimir c'est
épouvantable pour qu'il vienne avec moi
mais pourvu que jamais chercher chez moi
dans ma maison mais pourquoi cette fois
et dépêchons nous avons juste le temps
mais le temps de couilles je
t'expliquerai en route a franchement
s'il te plaît tu peux garder mon cas
cinq minutes alors oui oui oui avec les
élites jolie vient
de salah
[Musique]
c'est impressionnant la la la la mais
c'est un véritable sens bataille fait
que ces types là c'est presque rien mais
l'autre jour juste au moment de prendre
mon bain je ne retrouve pas mon poisson
rouge en caoutchouc et si on le cherche
dans les coffres et dans les tiroirs que
tu as fait tout ce désordre c'est ça
mais qui ça il fallait faire vite le
mans allait refroidir
et bien tu la retrouves et attend au
moins autant poissonsvous d'un oui mais
le bain était presque froid et bien où
était-il je l'avais oublié mon bain
précédent au fond de la baignoire
casimir et tous étaient arrivés hier
soir
ah non non pas fière non c'était à tort
enfin si le jour où je me suis disputé
avec mme solis nova propose lui de
chambre a dit la voix cet égard ya trois
semaines qui a trois semaines environ il
ya trois semaines que tu vis dans un
désordre pareil bah ouais et alors nous
casimir c'est dégoûtant tu aurait quand
même pu passer du coup d'aspirateur de
bas mais tu vas pas fait maintenant
pourquoi c'est plein de poussière plein
de nico tu vas finir
au tu crois ça me tente pas parce que
depuis quelques temps je que je commence
à tousser un peu tu as raison mon allée
vers anjou vite il faut que tout soit
propre vite mais pourrait le savoir
pourquoi tu es si près c'est tout à coup
face comme un tante adélaïde arrive ce
soir alors seulement ma maison dans un
tel désordre elle va être furieuse où
est ben j'ai compris il faut nous y
mettre tout de suite d'accord allez
sandras par ce côté de ce côté d'accord
moi je commence par ce côté c'est mon
rôle le tout est de bien s'organiser
liens et nous ne pas perdre de temps
venons mais ici il ya que des petits
objets fragiles heures avec micro dois
je vais le casser comme je suis plus
fort que julie je vais ranger les objets
lourds à voilà
voilà il suffit de bien s'organiser
n'est ce pas bon ici il n'ya plus rien à
faire tout est rangé là
je vais retourner là-bas et ranger ce
qui reste un il suffit de bien
s'organiser ses coûts
voilà
tu n'as rien arranger du tout voir mais
gt1 en train d'organiser le travail pour
un mot casimir tu exagères tu as raison
julie combat alors j'aimerais que tu me
donnes à la recette de la sagesse
[Musique]
à
je voudrais bien savoir comment il faut
faire pour devenir sage être toujours
obéissant comme les enfants sur les
images
surtout quand on est comme moi avec des
rêves plein la tête on a des gestes
maladroits s'il te plaît dix mois la
recette
en vérité
et plaisir
le
et c'est gagné tu peux bien sage sans
savoir et vert
[Musique]
les autour de toi
c'est merveilleux
arrive de temps en temps de partir en
claquant la porte ce n'est pas que je
sois méchant c'est la colère qui ment
pas
c'est à fait
il arrive que je me bagarre avec les
meilleurs de mes copains et je tape sans
crier gare
vérité
fait plaisir
ce que tu es
c'est gagner que de rien ce sont nous
serons rêveur
tu auras d'autres monnaies gens autour
c'est rare
[Applaudissements]
je veux bien essayer
pour diminuer bêtise de faire plaisir au
monde entier ce sera dur pas que tu dis
car en somalie
grèce monsieur du snap et le
julie mademoiselle futé compte aussi
parfois des erreurs
bien savoir comment il faut faire pour
devenir sage d'être toujours
obéissant comme les enfants sur les
images
agen surtout quand on est aux mains avec
des rêves
on a des gestes mal à mais j'ai bien
compris l'art
[Musique]